this next story is a political story but
it's also sort of a math story you know
I love a good math story and this math
story has to do with the fact that a lot
of people don't understand percentage
versus percentage points now two people
who do understand the difference please
accept my sincere apology that I have to
do this right now but the amount of
confusion over this over the last 24
hours
has forced my hand and I have to do this
so here's the headline Donald Trump's
approval rating is down 10 points or you
could also say 10 percentage points in
the last month so early in the corona
virus pandemic Donald Trump's approval
actually went up all the way up to 49%
in the gallup tracking poll it is now
down to 39% so Trump's approval went
from 49% to 39 percent that's a decline
of 10 points the problem here is that
some people don't understand the
difference between percent and
percentage points others understand the
concept but are using the wrong term and
just confusing other people so let's
just work through a very quick example
if someone has 50% approval and their
approval goes down by 10% strictly
speaking that would mean 50% 10 percent
of 50 is 5 that means if you have 50%
approval and approval goes down 10% you
go from 50 to 45 okay 10 percent of 50
is 5 so far I think we're clear if you
have an approval of 50% and it drops 10
points also said 10 percentage points
that's a decline of 10 actual points
meaning you went from 50 to 40 you lost
10 points 50 minus 10 is 40 the
confusion comes when we're talking about
percent changes to things already
measured in percent okay so in this case
our real-world numbers our Trump's
approval spiked to 49 and then drop to
39 in a one-month period that's a
10-point decline but it is about a 20%
decline to his approval right if you
lose 10 out of 49 that's a
about 20% and if you're now thoroughly
confused forget everything I've said the
news part of this story is that trumps
approval went from 49 to 39 that's a
very rapid decline in fact I think it's
the largest one-month decline that Trump
has seen at any time during his
presidency now there's good news and
there's bad news the good news is that
clearly Donald Trump's approval is not
immune from his actions in other words
the failed coronavirus response the
totalitarian instincts that came to
light after the George Floyd killing and
the protests that started this has hurt
Donald Trump that's good he's not immune
the bad news is that somehow 4 out of 10
Americans still think he's doing a good
job so this may be a good time to remind
you that when it comes to presidential
approval when you think about how
divided the country is presidential
approval adds up to a hundred but
there's not really a hundred points of
approval in play there's some portion of
people who for ideological reasons will
never approve of the job that the
president does I don't know if that's
like you know 10 percent 15 percent 20
I'm not really sure on the other side
you've got people who will never abandon
Trump no matter what he does that could
be 15 20 25 percent I don't know exactly
what it is right now but the point is
Trump's bottom for approval is not zero
and his top for approval is not 100 even
with George W Bush when things were less
partisan after 9/11 Bush saw a massive
spike in approval to 90 or 88 percent
something like that that was probably
his ceiling and those were the
absolutely most extenuating
circumstances so the point is when
Trump's approval moves from 49 to 39 49
39 it's in that range
it's really a lot more than that because
there the bottom is not zero and the top
is not 100 pick what numbers you think
it is with Trump it's probably something
like I don't think his approval no
matter what he does would go below 25 or
maybe even 28 something like that and I
don't think it would go higher than
probably 80 no matter what he does so in
the context of a range that is more like
28 to 80 a 10-point swing is pretty
significant but
there's a lot of people in this country
who will never abandon him it might be
for their own self esteem they don't
want to admit to themselves that they
made a mistake when they voted Trump in
2016 and the way to at least trick your
brain into thinking you didn't make a
mistake is to vote for him again in 2020
there's this quote incorrectly
attributed to Mark Twain it's still a
good quote just not Mark Twain the quote
is it's easier to fool people than to
convince them that they've been fooled
and along those lines we have to
understand why a lot of 2016 Trump
voters are going to vote for him again
some may abandon him and there's a very
small margin there that Trump can afford
to lose before it becomes almost
impossible to win re-election but
understand it's easier to fool people
than convened to convince them they've
been fooled and it is very relevant in
the times of Trump we'll take a quick
break and be back with much more right
after this make sure you're following me
on Instagram for the latest urban garden
and puppy updates at David Pakman